Casey neistat represents to most people,
I think what's possible through a career
on youtube.
He's had a successful short film career,
landed a multimillion dollar acquisition
from CNN for his company and his
insanely popular.
So how did [inaudible] get here after
being a high school dropout?
I think if you'd ask him,
he'd say what he has said a million
times already.
It was a lot of work.
Nice.
That's hardly the only one doing this.
He's part of a growing trend of people
that have been selling the silver bullet
of success to be
[inaudible].
The simple answer here is very simply
that you need to,
you need to work harder and faster.
There's really nothing else.
This idea of working harder is always
the answer.
It has an almost frat boy has fallen
into it and it's hard to Ms.
White.
So appealing.
It's an athlete's mentality.
Hardware,
there's a real drama and excitement to
the struggle and everything's always
within your control.
But is that all it took for Neistat to
go from broke to here?
I don't think so.
Hard work was necessary for nice debt
success,
but not sufficient.
Success is not solely a function of hard
work.
It's highly dependent on the quality of
the career opportunity or idea that
you're pursuing.
Think of the millions of people working
minimum wage jobs in America who are
working hard sometimes 80 hours a week
just to stay afloat for these people.
It's not about hard work,
but if hard work isn't enough,
how did Neistat becomes so successful?
So let me explain.
In the book outliers,
Malcolm Gladwell analyzes people who
excel at their craft.
He finds that good timing plays a big
role in why many people become
successful.
Even Bill Gates,
he talks about one of the secrets to
Bill Gates success was that he had
access to a computer.
That key could practice coding on years
before most people did.
So Bill Gates literally had thousands of
hours of programming practice under his
belt before anyone else got started in
this competitive advantage position in
perfectly to take advantage of the pc
revolution they started when the Altair
computer came out in 1975 well,
just like the computer revolution,
there has been a filmmaking revolution
since youtube came out in 2005 and light
gates.
Nice tech,
got a critical headstart in filmmaking
before most would be youtube or had even
picked up a camera.
See Neistat first got into professional
filmmaking with a guy named Tom Sachs in
2001 he developed a lot of his style
here and he continued honing his craft
of filmmaking with several videos and an
hbo special so that later in 2010 when
he fully embraced the youtube space,
his content was noticeably more refined
and substantive than his peers,
and this is part of the magic of
watching Neistat.
His style seems to come fully formed
right out of the gate,
whereas most youtubers have to find
their voice within the first few years.
Nice.
That had already found his with nearly a
decade of practice and your spelling.
So with this in mind,
the final piece of this story becomes
obvious.
Neistat's rise to be youtube favorite
blogger when nice.
That entered the vlog space in 2015 he
was joining group of loggers with little
film experience,
which makes it clear why nice.
That's quality stands above the rest.
[inaudible]
it's also why you see comments like this
on his luck all the time.
It's a bit like watching a professional
baseball player
play in a high school game.
He just had way more experience.
So Nice.
That's timing with filmmaking was
perfect.
How'd he started filmmaking earlier?
He might have been too far into a career
to switch to youtube,
which is why most career filmmakers miss
the youtube and how he started later.
He'd just be another Vlog or trying to
figure out his style.
But what happened was the combination of
the right idea at the right work ethic
and the right timing,
that's what made Casey Neistat
successful.
Okay,
so why does it matter?
The nice that somewhat undersells the
role luck played in his success.
Luck,
you know,
all that other education,
all that,
like it's not even in the same pie
chart.
I think what bothers me is a lot of
people see nice that I want to become
filmmakers like him and are told that
work because the only thing that's
standing in their way,
but this isn't actually true.
What made nice that go from a small
indie filmmaker to the cover of Gq
magazine in less than two years was
bringing nearly 15 years of professional
film experience into a field where most
people were total amateurs.
But that has changed.
The idea of being a Vlogger is worth a
lot less now.
Now that there are hundreds of people
occupying that space and producing
regular content and their contents
getting better.
And I guess I just want to tell anybody
with the hunger to be successful that
the next neistat probably won't be a
Vlogger.
It will be someone who utilizes a timely
competitive advantage to dominate the
market space or something like that.
I don't know.
I'm just a youtuber and as a Youtuber,
and this is the part of the video where
I tell you for the millionth time,
which you already know,
that you can subscribe and like and
watch another video if you want.
So,
uh,
yeah.
Thanks for watching.
I'll see you guys next Wednesday with
another video.